is Donald Sutherland if anyone close to
him can scream because Donald should
have more dignity where hey man how are
you alright so the first time it's good
to see you the first time bestie
obviously that's why I'm here and what's
up the first time I met Donald was many
moons ago and we were shooting a film in
Cape Town in South Africa where we were
rehearsing are about to start rehearse
and I was in a car park at a makeshift
production office and I looked over and
I saw the man and like can happen to us
at times when were familiar with
people's work through the years I had a
kind of a feeling that I knew but yet I
was intimidated as a result of that
feeling and as warm as Donald can be he
can be intimidating at times he has that
lion like visage and he's got you know a
very elegant but giant stature and I
said I'm gonna go over and say hello to
this man pay my respects I knew I was
gonna be working with him so I walked
over and I tapped him on the elbow
and he turned around and he said five
words to me that I've never forgotten to
this day and I've carried them with me
for whatever was 15 years he looked at
me and he said put out that [ __ ]
cigarette
[Applause]
Donald you complete me anyway Donald
Sutherland has the unusual distinction
of having been the first hippie he
became a hippie fictionally of course
some time before World War two and
participated in that conflict as a
hippie in the film Kelly's heroes
sergeant oddball it's just one of the
dozens of distinctive unforgettable and
absolutely unique characters that Donald
has created in his long and
distinguished career
there have been heroes and scoundrels
the prime movers of great events and
ordinary people victims of circumstance
lovers leaders soldiers of all ranks a
college professor and even Jesus Christ
in some cases he's been a few of these
things all at once on screen Donald has
led many lives but tonight we honor him
for the life that encompasses all the
others as well as the off-screen roles
of husband father grandfather
not to mention mentor inspiration and
lifelong anti cigarette lobbyist